oh sorry I saw the most cringe
interaction on Twitter what go on
um
brought the amount of secondhand
embarrassment I got so like I don't know
if you saw this is this Mr Beast thing
it was with this guy oh he faked the
thumbnail no no no which one let me show
you let me show you it okay this is it's
so bad oh my God the amount of crunch so
this dude tweet it you see this one no
just picked up this beauty I don't don't
I don't want to show the Twitter account
because I don't want to give this guy
any attention yeah just put up this big
agreement but I had an hour away from
Greenville The Hunt is on for Mr Beast
so he he's got a cardboard cut out and
he's going to take it to Mr Beast right
and Mr Bush replies saying go away I
don't want your stupid cut out I'm tired
of people harassing me and then he goes
the dude replies yes sir I've never been
more happy with the rejection in my life
oh my God and then this dude like does
like a video later on on this Twitter
being like
he goes like no see this is what I'm
talking about this is what my message
was about the whole time YouTube is a
platform keeps pushing us to be Cloud
chases oh my God I'm glad that I could
finally show that it had to stop I was
the one who finally you know got to to
show that it was time to change I can
see the YouTube title already with just
in in Brackets all caps social
experiment really like I'm like no
that's just coping bro I think he might
have deleted it because it was oh my God
this video of him
like like I will say just off that tweet
uh because you know this is definitely
not the first nor lost like you know uh
Jimmy dick writing tweet that I've seen
God the amount of Mr Beast dick writing
on Twitter holy [__] I'm like this dude
it is insane I know I believe it it is
cool of course he deleted it of course
he deleted that was that was Pete cringe
yeah he had a video of him in his car
with his friend driving from like his Mr
BEAST's Place being like yeah
I just I'm just so happy that he said no
because you know this has gone too far
like YouTube as a platform keeps pushing
this and it's about time it stops and
I'm glad that I could finally be upon
it's just like what the [__] no no
this dude again please don't show any of
this this dude hit in his Twitter bar
being like let me teach you how to grow
your YouTube channel from one to one
million times and it's just like bro
these absolute like like Barnacles of
human beings on the boat of YouTubers
just like absolutely desperate for any
surprise he hasn't added into his buyer
like officially rejected by Mr Beast
yeah I mean this is definitely like my
least favorite era of upcoming YouTubers
that are just absolutely like Bottom
Feeders to like they're like oh a crumb
of clout please no not the thing that
everyone is but like the people that
don't like this people that behave like
this yeah like absolutely like just I
mean just straight up like harassing
people it's just for class they've
always been cloudy
that's one big Advantage I think YouTube
has over like a lot of other platforms
which I haven't really seen anyone talk
about which is YouTube just has the
advantage where you know we we all we
all we have there'll be cringe young
YouTubers but at the end of the day
there are actually role models on
YouTube they're they're actually people
that have matured up with the platform
just not out of like you know out of
necessity just out of just people
growing up yeah maybe the people being
on the platform for a very very long
time and you know you look at you know
something like Tick Tock where there's
like the a [__] kid just committing
crimes in the UK or something like that
oh yeah yeah like uh like just just just
like just like the cloud chases uh let
me just commit crimes and film it and uh
that's how I gain attention and then it
works and you think about who are like
who are like the role models of tick
tock you know who is the one setting the
Press residents and no one's really
there right now just because it's such a
young kind of like platform and even
with twitch there is just like only like
a select few of people that have been
around that have set a good example and
are trying to set a good example you
know that's right
you're trying
well you know like as you were saying
like I feel like you know like I like to
think the three of us for example on
YouTube have like done a pretty good job
of kind of maturing with our audience
and I guess with the times not only
because we're just getting older in
general we've been on the platform for a
while but just like it's not even a
necessity it's just like like I never
like stopped to think like okay I've
done YouTube for this long now
um I gotta be an adult bro I gotta grow
up I was like no I never had to think
about that because it's just like now
that I am older and I've been doing it
for so long like it's just like have
become a natural progression to be like
well my audience of stuck around is
older yeah my experiences have gotten
larger and me as a person has just
gotten older so so
here is naturally my content now and
people like be like he's matured so much
what an amazing lad it's like no it's
really it's really not that like I feel
I feel it's really hard to do the
opposite of that you know to be like uh
you know kind of have that like uh I
don't know what's the nice way to put it
but just like you know have have a sense
to be like okay you know now that I am
older and there are still people
watching me you know whether I like it
or not people are going to see me as a
role model and you know I feel that
because YouTube as a platform for
example has been around for so long that
now there are people who have you know
who are there from the beginning who are
now here where they are today who have
kind of understood that mentality
whereas Tick Tock for example is such a
younger demographic and hasn't been
around for as long especially as like a
place where role models are born that I
don't think there are a lot of people on
Tick Tock to just be like you know I've
been on Tick Tock now for six months uh
I need to start maturing I need I need
to be that role model no one no one has
that mentality at the moment so like
maybe other people consciously think I
they should become Role Models yeah
that's kind of a weird thing
people who are like I'm a role model
yeah I've I've never I've never tried or
even think I'm anything like that as
deep as I've gone is um I'm like at
which age is it no longer socially
acceptable to talk about anime titties
anymore that's that's basically how deep
I've gotten with it yeah yeah exactly
I'm like when is this gonna be cringe uh
when am I when am I gonna stop doing
that and I haven't figured that out yet
I'm sure I figured that out a couple
years ago slowly adapt with the time I
mean my content has slowly changed over
the years it's less I mean there still
is it's like still like a lot of memes
and a lot of Comedy but there's a more
serious side to my content and I think
that just comes naturally with just
having less energy uh to deal with
[__] you know and again because you
as a person has matured as well right so
I just feel that's a natural progression
for anyone's content really you know
like you know like for like Conor my
content has been [__] way different
compared to like yeah ten years ago yeah
that's not like a conscious Choice it's
just like yeah I just am not with this
kind of thing for me
I know I mean you didn't want to be the
Black Butler guy forever Black Butler
and I was like I consciously want this
to change right but I was like I still
like creating stuff but just not this
stuff yeah yeah exactly um you know and
then uh I just kind of live stuff was
just really fun that wasn't conscious
though live was totally by accident yeah
but then I think there was a point where
I was like I would like to do this more
yeah but I'm kind of like consciously
doing it so I guess it's like a whole
it's experimenting a lot of happy
accidents and uh hopefully not wasting
time do you know do you know one social
media platform I've come back to being
fun and confident and this is gonna
sound so funny if you say Facebook I'm
gonna kill you Facebook
okay okay hear me out hear me out okay
sometimes every once in a blue moon you
make a post on Facebook and it's just a
nice comforted comforting thing knowing
that it's just your [__] family and
like your like the friends that you made
in high school that you don't know what
they've was what they've gotten up to in
[__] decades are you go on Facebook
every now and again you see like what
this person oh this person got married
oh this person has kids now and it's
just I don't know that's it's like
revisiting your hometown after being
away for like years and that's just
that's just like a noise I don't even
remember the whole time I posted on
Facebook okay I have a I don't know if
I've struggled this before I've a bit of
a guilty pleasure on Facebook all right
um I basically went
in the area I grew up yeah unless you
just went around every local group on
Facebook like neighborhood watches and
joined them uh what yeah
because they post just the funniest [__]
yeah so you should genuinely you should
look it up there's probably one because
there's a bunch of like 56 year old
people yeah let me let me find one that
was they were sworn yesterday that made
me Cracker
uh wait how do you look at the name of
this group it's just like okay don't say
the name okay let me see it's just like
it's just like that's the town I grew up
in and I I joined this group and it's
just like oh my God they post they're
just so funny and like there's like like
this one like yeah it's like this
it's a
I was like they'll just post pictures
right yeah like
does anyone recognize this person
they've been looking kind of shady yeah
it's just so funny it's like Skyrim NPC
Behavior yeah the day that was like just
funny van in the neighborhood is anyone
it's funny because they they obviously
because like this is like their world
yeah it's really fun just watching it
and seeing how like what kind of stuff
that they really care about right yeah
it's just kind of fun I don't know it
feels like participating in like the
people watching yeah yeah it's great
it's so fun yeah I guess that's kind of
what you're into but yeah I don't I
don't like actively look but sometimes
there's some fun stuff I don't I don't
actively look at my Facebook but I don't
know it's gone from Facebook being cool
to Facebook being the the platform that
your mom uses yeah uh to Facebook being
cringe and now I'm just like compared to
compared to the [__] Tick Tock
Twitter
um like twitch all these other social
media platforms it's just nice to go on
a social media platform and feel like
you're just in your back in your small
town and it's just like a small
community that you are familiar with and
you know yeah um and I don't know
there's there's there's a charm to that
and I every time I go on my Facebook I'm
like ah it's just nice to see what my
old mates what my old high school mates
are up to now you should join your local
news
you know what you know anyone who does
seem like something I'd enjoy all right
there's this post from Sue
whoever owns the dog that has barked
non-stop for an hour and a half at the
top of Village name please let your dog
in as it sounds in distress sounds like
a big dog and box three box at one time
other dogs are reacting to it so the dog
choir starts again yes I have a dog but
he doesn't bark constantly like this and
he would not be ignored like this in the
heat backlash expected but whatever and
this is expected 35 comments
why don't you go around and have a chat
with her or report it rather than
getting everyone involved it could be my
neighbor who has numerous dogs that bark
yep non-stop she doesn't care they're
all outside all day on the drive you
know what Sue is surely they're not in
the van and this heat it's just like
they're all heroes wear capes man it's
crazy the whole [__] Village comes
together to discuss a [__] dog
barking I love it it's so fun to watch
it's like the Town Hall in an RV okay
actually no I I I I know I know why I
like Facebook because going on the going
on that platform seeing stuff like that
it actually feels like
I just I just does anyone know why
missing peacock is
that's just a picture of it
there's a [__] peacock why do they
have this in a small town
yeah she cracks me up this [__] is so
wild it actually you you go on Facebook
you see these posts and it actually
feels like oh yeah these are people yeah
these are actually what they do yeah
these are people just dealing with some
like the most mundane [__] in their
lives and it's not like a million the
millionth Anime Avatar complaining about
some [__] thing in the latest Demon
Slayer episode I'm like oh these are
Facebook reminds me that there are
people who are behind all of these
accounts and there's there's a there's a
genuine I like that feeling I [__]
like that feeling you know what Facebook
you know what you're convincing me
you're convincing me to check out my
Facebook I don't know it makes me happy
knowing that like a lot of people just
have problems that are so minuscule that
is how they use the Spanish I don't know
man like peacock is pretty detrimental
yeah yeah that's kind of honestly if I
was in the neighborhood watching I saw a
peacock and just stroll up in my
neighborhood I thought you know I'd be
like what the [__] I just love the idea
of like there's a dog barking I don't
know where I'm just gonna go and
complain on the Facebook group yeah like
to me that is like I don't know why
that's just so funny and I I that's so
cute yeah it's so wholesome yeah but
obviously to them it's very serious
issue yeah yeah yeah yeah I think the
reason I found out about it is my
brother I think he parked his car
somewhere one time and he was like I got
in trouble with the neighborhood watch
all the Karens were oh [__] about me and
I was like what what the [__] I went on
this Facebook group and there was [__]
talking me I was like what the what the
[__] he's like who's this it's not
normally here he's like oh my God oh my
God yeah it's it's it's kind of like
it's kind of like The Slice of Life of
uh
okay because okay there's like a non-non
bureau yeah there's a thing right
there's a thing because a lot of people
to the to a lot of people these are some
of the biggest problems that they end up
dealing with and I remember like there
was okay this is this is like dredging
up a memory like a core memory of like
why one of one of the breaking points I
had when I decided to like pursue
YouTube as a career
um it was you know I was having this
meeting it was obviously in the BBC and
uh you know when you join a meeting and
not everyone's there right
so we had people from a lot of different
teams and we were waiting for someone to
join so you know you engage in small
talk and the moment I realized I was
going to leave was just uh I was trying
to engage in small talk with my like
some of my co-workers they are very very
different in age and one of them
mentioned that uh you know their bins
had been taken out like a day early and
then we got into this like five minute
conversation where we we got into this
five minute conversation because yeah
that's weird a little guy and then we
only we got into this conversation I was
like oh my bins get taken off on on the
Sunday and they're not like another guys
oh no no that's when the recyclables get
taken off for me uh actually it's like
the uh actually it's um the Monday for
me is when the bins get taken up and and
you know these are people you know very
very good at their job highly respected
um you know respect to them uh they've
been there as a company for like [__]
years and I I just remember thinking
I just remember thinking I'm like this
is this is not the life for me yeah this
is this is not the life for me but I
want to be talking about [__] been
days yeah yeah but you know what like
there is there is a big there is a huge
difference between the problems that
they are dealing with and the problems
that you know as someone who's on the
permanently chronically online on the
internet uh just some of the stuff that
we that we have to deal with some of it
because every when you're chronically
online everything just seems to be a
problem well but again like I think
that's what's interesting right is that
the the it's all about perspective like
you know to us we'd hear this
conversation about oh [__] suit lost
her peacock
that's hilarious but you know how why is
that a problem well you know or the
problem is so insignificant but to them
that's like actually eating peacock I
mean yeah well you know you know a dog
barking too loud right like but to them
that's like ruining their entire [__]
week whereas like the opposite can be
achieved of life so so what issues have
you had today it's like oh I go to I go
to bad I got a hate comment on my latest
video and it's not performing well
they're like just get off the internet
yeah like Savannah's like why is that a
[__] issue I've had a dog barking for
the first three weeks that's the real
issue you know so it's interesting to
see that like kind of discrepancy and
it's like you know eventually I feel
like for people like us when we do you
know eventually like retire or you know
quit making content like I feel we're
gonna look back on like those problems
that we had on you know during our work
and being like that was cute now I have
to deal with the dog barking yeah I mean
to me the dog barking seems way more of
a real problem than some of the [__]
people can play on Twitter yeah exactly
exactly
um and you know that's I I I kind of
crave that actually like I think some of
the best NPC you said like you mentioned
NPC Behavior I think one of my favorite
uh MPC like Oblivion videos was just
like an old British woman complaining
about like construction workers way too
early yeah do you know this one
something about something about just
like they're on the roof working and
she's down there like you have to stop
yeah yeah but she's just like I've had
it with you and then she like blocks the
driveway yourself she does something she
takes that ladder and then everywhere
and then the construction workers are
like oh oh if you have a problem you can
uh bring it up with the owner the owner
of the house told us when to start
construction other than the there's this
like line that she says which is the
most Oblivion NPC line I've ever heard
in my life which is she pauses and she
goes right I'll talk to them then
then she walks off and talks to the
owner and I'm like
uh British people and just Old Country
towns they are the real NPCs that's if
you want the true NPC I just see the
hard like side quests be gone after that
line and then walk off oh God yeah yeah
there's people believing that everyone
is out to [__] them yeah ruin their day
I wonder how do you define NPC Behavior
like it's like because it almost feels
like otherworldly in a sense of you're
so disconnected from reality that your
behavior seems so
I think the one thing that really sets
off NPC behavior is like as you said
with that video they just say some
things right the perception of reality
yeah where it's like normal people don't
say this in this situation or like maybe
it's like two on the nose you know I I
would I would count NPC Behavior as you
look at a person and it almost feels
like they are scripted they are
programmed they're programmed they are
programmed into the [__] Matrix or
whatever you know
um but then what makes NPCs feel like
NPCs is because they have just like a
set dialogue that's very
rigid or yes I think it's that whole
idea of like you can't imagine what it's
like being them yeah you know or it's
like it's so detached from your
perception of life where it's just like
I cannot even start to imagine what this
person is thinking or why they would do
these certain things because it's just
like not real yeah
yeah there's another one like a postman
in the UK it's always the [__] UK
we just sound like NPCs people in the UK
argue over they're just the [__]
stupidest thing it's all really getting
there whereas in America they it'll
it'll be a headline where ends with
someone getting shot yeah I think I
think it's just okay it's just [__]
filmed and stupid fighting yeah I think
it's just because of the way British
people argue is so passive aggressive it
just feels like a scripted MP true true
you know it's confrontational but you
don't immediately see the consequences
yeah yeah exactly it's almost as if you
know like in game you know an NPC can't
just suddenly uh wouldn't just suddenly
start punching you or something yeah
yeah you you you there are layers to it
in terms of you know choosing the right
and wrong dialogue options and that's
what it feels like talking to a British
person sometimes you know you choose the
wrong dialogue option they get a little
bit more passive aggressive a little bit
more Angry until finally it all kicks
off you know uh Peak NPC Behavior go to
It Go to
[Music]